, HOLD ON FOR ONE MOMENT.
MARQUARDT IS THERE IN
HE'S JOINING THE.AT YOU ARE SY'T
WORRIED.
THEY ARE CERTAINLY
D.TE
CAPIL.E' SIGNIFINT
THE LAS
MOMENTS.THE PROTESBEEN
RELATIVELILYFUINT FETHROUGH THAC
LINE
AM WG ASROTHE STEP OFF W SID
EYONTO THE
ITE AT LEAST HDO
ING,ALLYCLIM TE
CA
FELLOW PROTESTERE,
POLIC.E.
WE'VE HASE O
S.E HAD PROTESTERS CHOKING
STREAMING.
S HARD TY WHAT THECE PREE IS OU
T.YTHING SEEING
ISGETTING   THE CAPITOL WITH  P
RCEMENT, WOLF.
>> AND WMETHING
LIKE THIS COULD HAPPENTHAT'SHYW
YOU DON'T SEE MILITARY THE SCEN
GOING THROUGH,ACHING CAPITOL
WHNGE LAW., GETTING TO AREAS
DO THEY UNDERSY COUL
FOR WHATING? SENTENCE TO JAI
>> RorSS Y TH THET ALL.D BEEN LR
PARK POLIC.
HERE.
ERT
WER OTESPEACEFULOTHERS TO GO T
THERE HABE LF MOMENTUMUL T.T E T
E STNDOLF, LOONGT SC OTS TO Y SO
THTERRACE OFOLHEUGURATION WILL
DOUS ON ME FLAGSJ LOOKING  APPE
TO FEEL LIKE THEY DOE THE
UPPER
I'M NOT SEEING ANY ST OF SIGN
OF LAW FROM WHE I
AMHAT'S NOT GOOD A MATLYN CAPITO
HILL.
ILL FORE YOU SEEING?
>> Ror WOLF, LET'S O THE
DO.
IMETEROFS, 100, 150 FEETM THLDIN
ITSELF.
THE GENEL S NO
PERIMETER OF THEDING ITSELF.UGHY
UP THE STEPS OF L F
BUILDIS N ART RAS NO
EVENING IN RM
DAYS.
ONPIDRS E LIMBEDTHDING, UP TO T
TANOUND W TTT
SS FROM CAPITOL
POLICEE CAPITOL BUILNGS
OF PEOPLR THTORWG NU
E PREPARED FOR.
YOU KNS AS WELAS
ORTAGEHUIN
INGTON, D.C. TT
EDSIMPLY NEVER S L
TH, NOT JUST THE BREAC
BARR
BARRICADBUE ONTOLD PHYSICALLY D
HE, F WHAT'S GOINGPEN AND WHAT A
WAIN DEMONSTRATIONS IN
I HA ANYTHING LIKETHIS JOHKING
SE AS LL
THIS IS DANGEROUS WH YOU E PROTA
BARRICADE, GETTING INSIDE
EA, AND YOU'VE GOT THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UD ES,
THE LEADIP
THESE ARTICLES RIGHT NOW.G
AL SUDDEN WE SEE THIS
GOING ON.
>>LAIN AND
EVERY AMERICAN HASHE T
PROTVEN IF WHAT THEY'RE
PROTESG IS ACY
NOT.E PRESENCOURAGEDON, WHICH HD
PROTESTERS, ANINT HE GO  HIM,
WHIC'SD BEFOREE'S A CLEA FROACTH
AROU T ATE,
STPAST
TRESPASSTO PHIL' Y ARE NOT
POLICE, THERSIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH OF THEM.
THEY DO NOMONTKE
CLEARLY THEY
IS
IT IS RIGHT
WHAT HAV DO?
THE CAPITOAV ND B
THHEE.
IT'S QUIEMARKABLE THATHEF THE U
THE SPEAKER OFHE HOUSE, THE
HOUSE OF REPSEES, THE IT INSIDE
TH SUPPORTERS PRESIDENT.
ARYING TRCWAY EYE  RIGHT TO ESEC
INTOAPITOL, AND I CAN HEAR
CLEAR, WHEN YOU  A CHAOTIC
THERE'S  -- MANUWHAT ARE LRN
>> Rr: WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
AND E EE
PROTESTERS AREIDE THE
CAPITOL BUILDI
ES OESTERS, THERE HAVE WITNESSEE
SENATE -- JUST SENE
FLOOR, T S
CAPITOL.
AN ALERTT WENT OUT TL
EVERYBODY IN THEOL
IL PEOPLE TO MOVE
TO TAKEME THEM, STAY AWAY FRO
EXTERNAL DOORS A WIN.S IF YIN A
SPACE, FIND A PLACE TOIG
SEEK COVER
SILENCELECTRONICS.E IN A SCATIO
BUILDING UNTIL DIRECTED  T
U.S. CAPIT POLICE.
THIS ALERT ALS IF YOU'RE
AE OF THE
REMN CLEA
THE POLICE A AWAIT
R DIRECTION.
NG I HAVE
NEVER SEEN IN MYE COVERING
HAVE ACTY  NOT JUST
THE BUILDING, BUT HAVEE
INSIDE THET STEP
FROM WHERE. SENATORS HAVE
BEG ON THE SENATE
FLOO
FROM THE PICTURES  SEEING,
THERE ACTUALLY PROTESTERS
JUST OFF THEATE SECOND FLUOROF
STATES.
>> HOLD ON A SD,HI WHERE
WE SEE POLICE NO.
OU SEEING,?
S.
R JUST SAW A NUMBER OF S.E TAK
PHOTOJOUT CHRISTINE N
OVER THERE.
THERE.EN BANGS
OF FEW MINUTES -- THIS IS THE  N
THE WEST SID
T SIDE IT' VERY,
VERY.
WE SEO U
THE LITHEY GOT TO THE BALCONE T
E VE JUS
OM - I
AVENUE SIDE HIS HERE STARTEDTER
STAY UP THER
THEY'RE DOING?
IS AN IRESCENE. TALKING AUT AN
IS BE,N
WHERE PROTESTE THAT CLOSHE BUIL.
ON W OF THE PITOL,
VERY, VERY TENSE AS
WELL.
E CROWD IST
SIDE, BECAUSE THEY WERE O
REE THAT ON SPACE
T ELLIPSEERE WAS
TENSION THERE, LINESE
BREACHRE